it's time for roses and roses a
buongiorno everybody i'm lauren zima
welcome to a roses and rosa and I have
some Cabernet because we are in Italy my
Italian accent is stereotypical and this
episode of The Bachelor was all things
Italy in the best possible way you guys
we had pasta we had gelato
we had cute little winding streets we
had so much red wine and I loved every
minute of it isn't it lovely to take a
vacation in the winter by watching a
television show and pretending you're on
that vacation let's dive in I can't wait
to drink some wine and eat some pasta
and have amazing dates with women that
are left same and we know our he loves
dates and that's why Chris Harrison
comes in and says there's not gonna be a
rose ceremony oh my god it's all dates
just dates amazing dates Becca K first
date long haired Becca so long haired
Becca gets her first one-on-one since
the first one-on-one which we've worked
on shameless Club and Arie arrives in
this cute little red car which with this
car shipped over from France width M
this looked like the same car that broke
down on his date with Jack but very very
first one-on-one of this entire season
right now I feel like that one-on-one
date was forever ago yes it was and then
she says the stakes are huge higher than
they've been in this entire process yes
they are
it's later in the show then that first
one-on-one but Becca's nice and genuine
and sweets and smarts and I just like
her I really do and I feel like we're
just kind of stuck so I want to kind of
get back to where we were not a great
sign but then they do
something that I love you guys the date
and eat bread and cheese and a meat
selection and drink red wine what a
great date I love this let Italy B Italy
we don't need some weird French war boat
we are just gonna walk around in Italy
and enjoy them yes Ari gets unstuck with
Becca and they give us what I want to
give a shout out to which is a shot that
looks like the cover of a romance novel
ari and Becca are in silhouette the Sun
is set it is just it's really stunning
it's really something and then things
take a total turn Jacqueline Wow did not
see this coming
Jacqueline basically says I just have
like swirling doubts that she has all
these doubts about Arie and that she
even had them on their one-on-one date
which I did not notice when they were
full-on making out is it like any part
of you that feels like you can just stay
and feel it out kendall comes in is like
the resident therapist again which i
love she's counseling her and saying do
what you got to do and this brings us to
jacqueline going to Ari's hotel room and
what I believe to be the first time a
woman has gone to the bachelors room of
her own volition this whole season I
don't think it's happened yet again this
season is a slow burn anyway I'm sorry
so Jacqueline I think breaks up with him
she tells him it's not gonna work
but then she makes out with him and then
she's like really it's not gonna work
but then they make out some more and
she's like honestly this is not gonna
work for me but I'm really attracted to
you what a push-pull dr. Watson so was
Jacqueline sound in her decision re even
said that if she changed her mind he had
led her right back in which I thought
was lovely of him to figure out how we
really feel about Jacqueline I want to
bring JC in you guys might remember when
JC advised that Ari was and
laughs so he thinks so we're gonna get
JC's quasi psychiatric tape from
Jacqueline I really liked how Jacqueline
was the good kind of selfish she said a
couple of great things I liked she said
that she was in love but she wasn't sure
that this was the love and also she's
not willing to give up her education six
more years of schooling for anybody I
think that's that's cool
the good kind of selfish Thank You JC
yeah by the way guys drink every time
you see them drinking red wine in Italy
[Music]
Cheers oh that's really good is good re
as we know loves wine loves his red wine
he's been drinking it all season and I'm
just really happy for him that they are
here in Italy for him to enjoy the
literal fruits of his labor Jacqueline
is leaving and everyone is crying it is
so sad it's like the end of summer he's
gotten close over these two months
they've done new things when your
friends gotta go you look great
Lauren B and Ari's date we get up the
run and jump hello we always get these
when I travel I love staying on the back
did you practice this for them again we
get a great date ari says they're just
gonna explore this little town and
that's especially a great date for
Lauren B because as we know Paris wasn't
for wealthy they get some gelato great
and Lauren B says that this town in
Italy is very Italian
when they sit down to dinner things get
more deep and Lauren B says she's afraid
to introduce why am I still calling her
Lauren B there's only one Lauren left at
this point maybe I was trying
differentiate between her myself
Lauren says that she is afraid to
introduce Ari to her parents because
they met her ex-fiance previously and it
wasn't that long ago did we ever find
out why her and her ex fiance broke up
did I forget this guy's please let me
know in the comments I can't remember
why did they break up that seems
critical anyway then things get even
more awkward than when Lauren and Ari
are silent in that ari leaves the date
it's very obvious to me of it I feel
like I'm starting to fall in love with
you
so not only who's it silent it's silent
because she's alone this is when I got
frustrated because we didn't see where
re-wet did he go to have a conversation
with a producer to get some perspective
that's what I would guess I'd like to
see that conversation break down the
fourth wall tear down the fourth wall
please I'd love to see the moment
and then he comes back and she's like
are things good are things bad you're
not explaining where he went and he just
says I'm falling so do you play in love
with you it's crazy
Wow okay so this seems pretty big to me
you guys I don't really know how Lauren
B isn't the front-runner at this point
even though we've been kind of confused
because Ari seems really into each woman
on each date and car you love States
Lauren B he's so into her and he can't
explain why I want it's so bad for us
and I can't explain why I wish you could
Ari
it's a TV show please explain what not
it just makes me want to grab her and
tell her I love her that sounds like you
want to do something but you can't
because you know you saw this reality
show you know
and then a cien date and I'm not gonna
spend a lot of time on this because it
could get confusing I almost wonder if
the CN date was filmed before the Lauren
B date because Ari says he's been crazy
about her for a long time and we get the
run and jump and the pasta and it's
great and then he says nope he's not
feeling it and by she's great
he thinks she's great it's surprising
that he sent her home but she handled it
great sans great hope to see you again
babe and everyone is shocked Becca gives
great shocked face shout-out to
short-haired Becca for it that and this
is when things start to take a turn on
Becca Diaz says that Becca is really not
being grounded in her reaction to see
ends departure this date was
quintessentially Italian ari is the
Godfather because he makes a lot of dad
jokes
Kendall is the consigliere because she
advises Tia turns into the rat because
she rats out Becca and Becca you guys
spoiler if you haven't seen it is gonna
sleep with the fishes amazing Luca Brasi
sleeps with the fishes I don't like
feeling like I'm penny or talking about
people tia tells Arie that she just
doesn't think that Becca is really
mature enough to be here but I have to
say she handles the tattletaling in a
pretty legit way I didn't find anything
nefarious or malicious about this she
was just kind of telling Ari how she
felt but Becca is very upset by this and
probably understandably so someone's
talking about her and she's crying and
Aria is comforting her and he is in
prime dad Godfather of mode
[Music]
what is it Kendall I'm really excited to
meet your family
Kendall gets the first rose and then it
becomes a two-on-one Tia versus back up
at dinner dinner date showdown here's to
being open and honest and direct and
finding love at the end of this thing
Tia Cheers this to being honest and
direct and finding love here so she's
cheering to what she's just done and
she's cheering to what she wants to do
better keeps asking Ari to have faith in
her
[Music]
but you can tell by his responses that
he's losing faith in her and Tia gets
the rose not our little short-haired
Becca I was sad about this probably my
first emotion about a departure this
season because I like short-haired back
up what's sad an Italian you know prego
no Bella not a prego okay she is your
little girl I know that you're very
protective of her heart leafy harder
I can find you so we get a promo for
hometowns and these families look
intense Ari has been making his dad
jokes but now he's got to face the dads
and they say stuff like you're not gonna
hurt my back up
we're her guard dogs killing and
speaking of the Godfather they do they
are today Wednesday Friday Sunday
Saturday bachelor winter games premieres
today you guys and it airs this Tuesday
and Thursday and then next Tuesday and
next Thursday so Tuesday Thursday
Tuesday Thursday today Wednesday and
then of course we have just a few
episodes of The Bachelor left thank you
so much for watching
roses and Rosie please leave your
comments below and I will love and
relish the opportunity to respond to
them as they love talking about this
show so great I need to learn a second
to tell you thanks everybody have a
great night a ciao
[Music]